Rick: There's your *burps* stupid hat.
Beth: dad, you can't talk to Jerry that way anymore
Beth: We're a real family now in many ways things will be like season 1, but more streamlined
Beth: now Jerry
Beth: And I are happily married parents and the idea that I was motivated by a fear of you leaving can be eschewed
Summer
; Eschewed? you've never used that word. Maybe you are a clone
*laughs*
Not like Rick would tell us
*all laughs i think Jerry snorts*
Holy crap everybody so that was a Rick and Morty finale
I think the biggest surprise is wondering whether or not Beth was still a clone
And why they chose this episode in particular to be the finale and not episode 7
Which was more like a big mythology episode, so we'll try to address that after I do Easter eggs
But I'm also gonna do a season 4 video
and I'll explain what my weekly bonus video schedule is gonna be for Rick and Morty now that we're in the off season and when
I think that season 4 is actually gonna get here
So be sure to subscribe to get everything if you're just finding me for the first time
They'll be giveaway stuff at the end of the video - so obviously. This is Rick versus the United States president
That's all it really ended up being there was a small name drop for evil Morty, but he was really only referenced
He didn't physically appear in the episode
neither did Tammy the
Federation
Phoenix person any of that big stuff so obviously they're all leaving that for season 4 the title of the episode the rectory and Morty
Tate is a reference to the movie The Manchurian
Candidate, but is also a bit of a gravity falls Easter Egg the stanchion candidate even though the plot of both of those episodes is
a little bit different
But it seems like they were only using the episode to wrap up the divorce storyline like basically
Reset everyone back to season 1 as Beth breaks the fourth wall at the end of the episode
I guess she knows that she's inside a television show now -
But the whole president story was kind of like a bad breakup that Rick then later reset when he pretended to be
Fly-fishing Rick so when they opened the episode they sort of used the 24 digital clock text at the bottom
They don't use the 24 transitions sound though Rick burns the hell out of people that play minecraft
Then kind of burns himself like he's I'd autistic people play this because I'm really loving it
So I guess Rick is saying that he's autistic when he breaks the fourth wall again
That South Park did it four years ago
He's talking about the episode where they do that how do you tame a horse in Minecraft where they put child lock on everybody's TVs?
They have that joke about them flying the helicopter all the way to their house when Rick can travel anywhere
He wants in an instant because there's always TV shows where people wonder how?
Characters get around so quickly like how did he get here if he was just over here on the other side of the earth?
So they said that several times of the episode don't you realize that Rick could teleport everywhere he can travel anywhere
He wants the janitor that the googas kill at the beginning of the episode is drawn to look exactly
Like one of the writers of the episode Mike may had he appears in some of those behind the scenes features that they do
most of you probably know that the googas was an old channel 101 skit that Dan Harmon and Justin roiland did a
Long time ago almost 10 years ago. I talked a little bit about it last week
Right
They think of themselves as
Ghostbusters the device that Morty's using to detect the googas looks exactly like the device they used to detect ghosts in that first
Ghostbusters movie there were a whole bunch of special underground rooms in the White House
So if you were a conspiracy theorist about the government this
Episode is probably like candy to you because there are so many things that they imply about our nation's history and some of our most
famous presidents
So there's the kennedy tunnels the truman lounge the McKinley dump in the Lincoln slave
Coliseum later in the episode when they're fighting each other they crash through most of those rooms
But I don't think we ever make it to the slave, Coliseum
But there's a bunch of extra stuff that you spot in there like when they crash into the Truman lounge there's a bowl of
coke just waiting to go in case anybody happens in and he throws it at Rick
So I guess Rick is super high by the end of the episode
But if you remember toxic rick versus rick going around their house
Just grabbing all kinds of hidden secret weapons. That's kind of the thing that they have going here
There's all kinds of hidden weapons all over the White House that he tries to take Rick down with when I saw these kids pop
out at first
I thought they were the kids from the shining
But they actually look a little more like the kids from escape to Witch Mountain
Which is basically just two little kids with psionic abilities
So then when they crash through the McKinley h**ker dump you spot a bunch of fake news sets that looks like they
Filmed and faked the moon landing along with the Kennedy
that's actually a pretty big one and there was actually the callback to Episode one
where Rick is watching that and starts to think that it's an inside job along with the jungle set and
Washington Crossing the Delaware so it's like they're saying that a lot of our nation's
biggest most WTF events were all completely faked
There's even a UFO said, too
But they do say that there's an area 51 where they're keeping
poseidon locked up a
Living god that won't submit
So there's a lot of contradictory things like they do have a lot of fantastic stuff
But a lot of the real-life
fantastic stuff that America has supposedly done was I guess fate based on what brick and Morty is saying so like I said if you
really love government conspiracy theories
This is your episode but jumping over to the Beth's storyline
So this is like the big question after the episode is she really a clone in the way they left it. They're like well
We'd never really tell you if she was she asserts herself as a clone a couple times in the episode
But I think the real clue is in that first conversation. She's having with him when he says wait a minute
You're not just
Pretending to believe me when I say that you're not a clone because I would have to terminate you if you became self-aware
So that really just means that they're both lying to each other
But I think that Rick's
Reaction to her at the end of the episode when he comes to the cabin says it all he says Beth
You're my daughter, and you have to remember that Rick is
c-137 Rick
But he's jumped into several different bodies over the course of the season just season 3 so even in last week's episode
He told the original Beth from this reality. You're not my Beth, but all Rick's love
They're Beth's so ultimately it doesn't matter if her consciousness is in a different body. He's going to love the clone
Just like it were the real Beth, so he's going to treat her the same way which means that he won't kill her
So he's kind of stuck with the family because clone Beth
Actually does love Jerry and that's one of the other times the Beth is like yeah
I'm basically a clone because I'm not the real Beth because I love you
And there's even all that weirdness with summer like she's super cool with her if the results are too strong make sure you
Use protection any time a big character like that goes through a 180 overnight
You just had to be suspicious about stuff like that
But hopefully that answers the question about clone Beth like she's going to be treated like original Beth from this reality
And she's effectively the exact same thing and by the end of the episode when she says Rick would never tell us
Otherwise so it's sort of their way of saying that they're never definitively going to say yes. This is a clone
No, this is original Beth like you just left to wonder even though. I think all the clues are there. She's a clone
It's just that they're never gonna call her out as that
You probably picked up on Dan Harmon's voice too when they were at the crappy mall like they get really meta with those subtitles
Whoever's typing them when they go to the different locations
I guess really hates this malted type crappy mall then it's Dan Harmon's voice on that, PA
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs when they went to see that tiny
Civilization the people that found them in the hazmat suits call them elgu Gatos
Which I guess is their version of Google and Spanish, but Rick and the president go back and forth
They make a couple movie references shrinking 70 style is a fantastic voyage reference
This is she a 60s movie, so they're a little off on the decade
But the pills and the ship look like they're right out of
Fantastic Voyage and inner space then when they make the joke about growing like you're in a 50s movie
That's attack of the 50-foot woman. There's a whole bunch of visual gags like he's wearing a top with no bottom
So you basically have naked?
President Keith David for a large portion of the episode like he just walks with his bits
Swinging around in the wind we learned that Rick is afraid of pirates and the government apparently gets all of its information
about him from his Wikipedia page
But Rick fixes Israel and Palestine by getting them super high and taking them to a Star Wars Cantina
Then there's a big conspiracy tear where Rick calls himself out
And he's sort of calling out
Conspiracy theorists too when he says I'm Doctor Who and this mother I could be a hologram
I could be a clone I could be a clone being controlled with a
Headset evil Morty style buy the real Rick and Morty that are having with your mother
so that's sort of your evil Morty wink like being controlled with a
Headset by another version of Rick and Morty so that's about as close as we get to evil Morty in the episode
People thought that this was them taking a swipe at conspiracy theorists
But they're also working in some real things from Rick and Morty like they've actually done some of these things
And I forget who you are
But somebody in my timeline said that on the back of Jerry's rope here are the Chinese characters for a week
We just is totally appropriate for Jerry's character, but I don't know why he would wear a robe that actually said a week
Maybe that's just Jerry being stupid not realizing
What's going on?
But if there was any confusion fly-fishing Rick at the end of the episode is our Rick
pretending to be fly-fishing Rick so that he can stay on this reality and sort of
Reset his relationship with the president because before he has it out with his family
He's intending to go somewhere else, but there are a couple of times in the episode where he says
It's a real bitch to go to a different reality
that's the writers saying that we're not just gonna like wash our hands of this storyline and jump to another reality and
reset all this character development
That's happened this season so
Morty's gotten a little bit smarter more assertive so the title of the episode seems like it's more of a reference to that
Morty being controlled by Rick most of this season and then Morty sort of shaking off that control and also based on what Rick says
To Jerry at the end of the episode it seems like he's his true nemesis now like when they say
Arch-nemesis in the episode Jerry is the ultimate villain for Rick that he'll never be able to take down
Even though you have other people like evil Morty swirling in the background that seemed like more traditional
Villains like Jerry beats Rick the things that you never thought would be able to happen
He's this cancer that they can't get rid of hijacking his family, so Rick is stuck with them
And that's why he's so pissed off at the end of the episode
So sort of my final judgement is that it was actually a good episode of Rick and Morty but is a finale
It was kind of weak like you hoped that they'd build up to something a little bit bigger so like episode 7
Probably would have been a better finale
but they would have had to wrap up the divorce storyline so you can kind of see how they
structured things because a lot of this stuff that they did with the divorce wouldn't have worked in episode 7
So it's a little bit messy, but like they say they're resetting things to more of a season 1 style
So we'll see what season four looks like but as for the mr.
Poopy butthole post-credit scene that was them sort of calling out the fans like hey
Just don't sit around and do nothing waiting for season 4 to get here
But you do see the pictures in the background so I guess this mr.
Poopy butthole actually did have adventures in these past couple of years with this version of the family, but again
It's just a riff on the post-credits scene from season 2
And I think he was a little more specific in that version of the scene this time
They're a little more general like it's gonna be a long time before season 4 gets here
But I'll talk a little bit about that when I post my season 4 video that'll be tomorrow
But let me know in the comments if you spotted any other
References that I didn't mention in the episode and let me know what you thought of it in general
I know it's gonna be very divisive
But there's a new round of the merch giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on this video congratulations to the last winner Brill Chan
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
you can click here for more Easter eggs, and you can click here for brand new flash season 4
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight